Gold is the most powerful metal on earth
and Russia is one of the world's leading
suppliers of it it all began in 1745
when a peasant named tiara fade Markov
while looking for crystal found
something else a tiny gold speck inside
a piece of quartz his discovery changed
the history of Russia and the world
three years after Markov found the first
golden Russia mines like these popped up
all over this region it was grueling
work to get an ounce of gold miners had
to cut grind and wash more than 7 tons
of raw ore for the next 66 years this
was the only way to extract gold in
Russia until Leo Bruce Nelson made a
revolutionary discovery a son of a gold
miner verse Nielsen discovered that gold
flecks also existed in the sediment of
local riverbeds he then developed an
ingenious panning technique based on a
simple principle Gold is heavier than
rock and sand and if washed properly it
will sink to the bottom of a pen by 1816
only two years later half of all gold in
Russia was obtained using person
instance method and because it was now
accessible to everyone people from all
over Russia flocked here to get rich
quick and so the Russian gold rush began
it wasn't long before person its ins
method caught on around the world in
1848 gold was discovered at Sutter's
Mill in California and Russian teams
even came out to teach the Americans how
to pan for it so you could say that
without the Russian gold rush the
American gold rush might never have
happened
[Music]